tout d'abord merci beaucoup d'
être avec nous aujourd'hui mr.  bin berners-lee
le véritable honneur de vous avoir dans l'émission
et mon plaisir parlons de votre
enfance vous êtes tous les deux votre mère et votre
père étaient des mathématiciens et des
programmeurs informatiques vous avez déjà mentionné qu'il
y avait beaucoup de discussions scientifiques
à la maison mais quand  vous vous rendez compte que la
science était une vocation pour vous, je pense que
ce n'est pas une réalisation aussi soudaine que d'
avoir constamment été
sur cette voie avec le genre de
mathématiques toujours utilisé dans la
conversation et très scientifique, donc l'
attitude avec mes deux parents, je pense
qu'il y avait  a il n'y avait pas donc vous n'envisagez jamais de
faire autre chose que de la
science pas vraiment j'étais tellement parce que
j'aimais construire des choses sur l'
électronique appréciée d'un côté et une école où
j'étais pouvait aller en maths et donc entre les
deux et moi les trains électriques aussi bien
formés  ouais commençons par l'
année 1999 avec un mariage alternatif quand tout a
commencé chez le PDG et à ce moment-là pourrait-
on dire que vous ce que vous vouliez faire
était simplement de  résoudre un
problème de communication avec une nouvelle équipe au CER n à
Genève qu'en est-il d'Amélie entre l'
équipe c'était le problème la
frustration était de savoir si nous avions tous ces
différents systèmes qui existaient p pour que les
gens gardent une trace de leurs documents
et des systèmes en cours d'exécution  différents
ordinateurs et donc il y avait ce n'était pas
que je voulais en faire un autre, j'ai
réalisé que le problème était que j'en voulais
un si vous aimez un système virtuel
mm-hmm qui les inclurait tous et
donc c'est tellement vrai que j'ai réalisé qu'il avait
être quelque chose d'universel devait être de
conception très très générale ouais et à ce
moment-là vous aviez déjà inventé l'
hypertexte il avait déjà dix ans
mais je n'avais pas besoin d'un
système d'enquête supérieur donc j'avais un programme cool inquire
qui avait des liens  c'était dix ans
avant oui donc déjà j'ai joué
avec l'idée de
cartes de correspondance qui se connecteraient les unes
aux autres et c'est tout bien qu'à l'
époque et en 1980 les
ordinateurs n'avaient pas de graphiques  c'était tout,
c'était tout en tapant et en voyant que ces
cartes défilent sur l'écran mm-hmm est-
ce vrai que la première application qui tue était
un annuaire téléphonique pour le Web ouais le
problème est de savoir comment amener les gens à
prendre l'étrange nouvelle  morceau de logiciel
mm-hmm et il s'est avéré que ce que
tout le monde au CERN partageait était qu'ils avaient besoin
d'accéder à l'annuaire téléphonique et l'annuaire téléphonique
était stocké sur un ordinateur mm-hmm
un sur l'ordinateur central et nous avons donc
mis un serveur central dessus  et donc la
motivation pour les gens d'utiliser le mot
web était juste de pouvoir accéder à l'
annuaire téléphonique et une fois qu'ils avaient le navigateur web,
ils avaient beaucoup de choses
quand avez-vous réalisé que votre invention
allait être grande il y avait  non encore
aucun moment particulier, il y
a eu la charge sur le premier serveur, mon regard
sur les journaux au cours de la première année a été
multiplié par 10, puis l'année suivante,
la charge sur le nombre de visites sur le
premier serveur a augmenté d'un  facteur de 10 à
nouveau l'année suivante a augmenté d'un  facteur
de 10 contre Laurel agarics la
vente algorithmique est complètement verrouillée dans une croissance
exponentielle très très exacte mathématiquement
donc il n'y a pas un seul point c'était
comme si j'étais en quelque sorte comme le Big
Bang mais continu ouais c'est une belle
analogie dans votre livre tissant le  Web
publié en 1980 et 99,
vous avez mentionné qu'en 1991, plusieurs
services Web différents étaient déjà en
concurrence et qu'il
était en quelque
sorte plus facile de se faire concurrence.
système un celui-ci bien il y avait un
moment où l'autre optait pour un système plus simple
et eux et en fait la façon dont vous
pouviez regarder les graphiques de la quantité
de déchets
ramassés sur le réseau fédérateur Internet
qu'ils mesuraient et un gopher se développait
de manière exponentielle dans le Web était en bas ici, de
sorte que le Web était moins et puis
il y avait un point particulier où les
gens qui dirigeaient le Gopher à l'Université
du Minnesota ils  envoyé un e-
mail pour dire que vous ne savez probablement pas
aujourd'hui et pas beaucoup, mais nous pourrions
éventuellement facturer à l'avenir, donc chaque
pensée oh je n'étais pas libre que nous pourrions
avoir paiera doit être comme des redevances
et à ce moment-là le trafic gopher
tanked et le World Wide Web a continué
d'augmenter que ce qui vous a
incité à le garder gratuit eh bien, il
est clair qu'à cette époque, il y
a beaucoup de gens qui ne l'utiliseraient que
s'il était complètement libre de droits mm-hmm
les gens qui travaillent dans leur garage ouais juste
pour vous savez qu'ils travaillent pour le
monde ils ne travaillent pas pour eux-mêmes
ils ne voulaient pas être des
gens royaux travaillant pour une grande entreprise aussi
s'ils le feraient s'ils travaillaient sur le  coder
le code gopher qui pourrait rendre leur
entreprise responsable d'énormes
paiements sur toute la ligne, de sorte qu'il
deviendrait très important de s'assurer
que le Web était déclaré
libre de droits, mais c'était votre philosophie
depuis le début jusqu'à  gardez-le
www.free, nous n'avons jamais pensé à faire payer
qui que ce soit pour cela, car pour
revenir à la philosophie antérieure, il devrait
être universel, c'était une grande demande, je
vous fais dire que cela va être une
chose universelle, vous pouvez mettre n'importe quoi dessus  donc
il y a des gens si vous demandez que
vous ne pouvez pas aussi demander deux centimes par
grenier oui en 1999 une interview vous avez
exprimé vous avez exprimé une peur vraiment profit
peur qu'à l'avenir il y ait un
réel danger que les gens aillent tous librement
à un grand portail c'est ce que vous avez dit
et tous les revenus publicitaires provenant
de la même source, cela ferait
boule de neige dans un endroit emmons où
tous nos besoins seraient satisfaits et
et je cite dans un grand et c'est
votre citation commerce
Vatican it  c'était en 1999 pensez-vous que
Facebook est devenu ce portail je pense
que beaucoup de gens il y a plusieurs grandes
entreprises dans l'espace et
dans différents pays ils se font
concurrence mais je pense que beaucoup de
gens se sentent  que la domination de
certains grands monopoles particuliers
commence à vraiment nuire à l'innovation,
ils ont le sentiment qu'en lançant un nerd, une
entreprise étonnante, ils ne peuvent jamais vraiment
rivaliser, ils ne peuvent pas vraiment rivaliser sur le
Web ouvert et je pense que les gens sont si tristes pour
l'esprit original  du Web que
tout le monde aurait son propre site Web
et que ce site Web serait leur propre
création complète et qu'ils
se démarqueraient sur le Web
sans intermédiaire voyez-vous cela comme une
dérive du ddd primal vous avez la
philosophie filus de d  du Web la
commercialisation de tels services
oui je pense que la philosophie originale
du Web était décentralisée c'était une
force montante décente et cela permettait à
des groupes de personnes ad hoc de faire des
choses qu'ils ne pourraient jamais faire avant je
pense que c'est un  partie vraiment importante
du genre de l'éthos du Web et je
pense que beaucoup de gens pensent que je suis
vraiment personnellement triste à ce sujet et
je suis personnellement préoccupé par  À quel point
avons-nous, nous concevons en essayant de concevoir de
nouveaux systèmes dans le laboratoire ouais où les
gens pourront jeter leurs propres
données ouais et contrôler où ils mettent
leurs propres très bons mais n'avons-nous pas
accès mais allons  dire pour les femmes c'est
que je suis l'avocat du diable et je
vous dis que Mark Zuckerberg a un fils chef
des rêves que vous caressiez sur la
convivialité du futur web
pensez-vous que c'est certaines façons qu'il
a c'est vrai que c'est ça  la
convivialité, c'est ce que vous envisagez
pour l'avenir du Web dans les
années 90, je pense que chaque fois que vous avez le
monopole d'une grande entreprise, vous pouvez toujours
passer beaucoup de temps sur
l'interface utilisateur. America Online l'a fait,
mais c'était le fournisseur de monopole
et  tout le monde a été étonné des
choses qu'America Online a faites et
quand Internet est arrivé, America Online a
essayé de prétendre qu'Internet
n'existait pas ou qu'Internet
faisait partie d'AOL, puis ils ont réalisé
qu'ils devaient  avouez qu'en fait, la zone
n'était qu'une partie d'un plus grand chemin, je
pense que ce qui se passe, c'est que vous pouvez rendre
le jardin clos magnifique à l'intérieur, mais
à la fin, tous les efforts que vous déployez
pour rendre le jardin clos magnifique
ne peuvent jamais rivaliser avec la jungle à l'
extérieur ouais  une croissance folle gratuite
pensez-vous qu'il reste encore assez de
jungle pour contracter ces gros
monopoles je pense que non je pense que Queen je
pense qu'il y aura peut-être un
point de basculement à l'avenir lorsque les gens commenceront à
vraiment récupérer leur voix individuelle
mais vous savez dans  le je pense que ce n'est pas dans
le Cid's vous connaissez la pièce de pyaar
karne quand son Drake dit au roi
c'est une phrase vraiment célèbre
dit roderick et le combat et je cite le
combat a cessé faute de soldats
pensez-vous qu'à l'avenir là-bas
sera comme assez de gens conscients de ces
débuts du web pour pouvoir remplir
d'un contrat de clic ce type
de monopole de pensée ouais je pense que c'est à l'intérieur de
Facebook et Twitter et tout  ces grandes
entreprises oui je pense à cause de la façon dont les
gens sont câblés je veux dire nous sommes ici
nous sommes à la conférence web mmm à
Morella que c'est plein de gens des
centaines de personnes ici qui sont toutes
vraiment excitées par la démocratisation
efficace du web  et donc je pense que
beaucoup de gens aussi quand ils
s'assoient naturellement, ils aiment opérer dans un
monde où ils aiment être responsabilisés, ils
aimeraient pouvoir se connecter à qui
que ce soit et cette
alimentation, je pense que c'est très motivé mais
que diriez-vous  disons que c'est la plus grande menace
pour le développement développé
du Web comme vous l'imaginez
à l'époque depuis le
début, c'est toujours la plus grande
qui a toujours été que quelque chose
contrôle Internet quelque chose un
gouvernement une grande entreprise si ça devient  une
mainmise sur Internet ouais
donc ça voit tout ce qui se passe il
vous espionne et ça commence à
ralentir le trafic vers différents endroits
alors vous savez maintenant nous utilisons le web s  o une grande partie
de nos vies que quiconque contrôle
le Web finit par être en mesure de nous contrôler
ouais la confidentialité a été un grand
débat entre spécialistes et grâce à
Edward Snowden cela ne fait pas partie du
débat public pensez-vous qu'une plus grande
confidentialité en ligne sera atteinte  avec
des lois améliorées ou comme Jeremy Zimmerman, un
gars que vous connaissez comme bien, j'ai dit quadrature
sec dans un livre il y a des années à la suite
d'applications de cryptographie faciles à utiliser
devenant de plus en plus répandues dans le
monde, je pense que la confidentialité n'est pas seulement une question de
cryptographie mais  pour une chose, par
exemple, n'importe quelle application Web maintenant, nous pouvons faire de la
cryptographie à l'intérieur de l'application Web, vous pouvez
créer une application Web qui parle à une autre
version d'elle-même en utilisant la cryptographie, car
la pile d'applications Web sur le
logiciel d'application Web Web a un potentiel cryptographique ouais
tour donc c'est excitant et cela
signifie que vraiment toutes sortes de choses
peuvent être construites là où les crips par cryptage
sont là où c'est normal aussi bien sûr je
passe très largement à tous les liens
étant en  crypté, donc passer à l'utilisation de HTTPS
au lieu de http, de plus en plus
de trafic sur le Web est
crypté, alors maintenant oui, nous nous dirigeons
vers cette
confidentialité mondiale cryptée, mais ce n'est pas tout,
nous n'avons pas seulement besoin de ça  Je pense aussi
parce que, par exemple, si vous
êtes médecin, vous finissez par voir beaucoup
de données sur les gens ouais, vous devez avoir une
responsabilité, donc nous devons aussi avoir
beaucoup de
discussions sur la façon dont nous sommes autorisés
à  utiliser des données pour que je puisse, en tant que médecin,
obtenir des données lorsque je sauve
une urgence à quelqu'un lorsque je suis dans
la rue avec une ambulance, je peux peut-
être automatiser simplement utiliser n'importe quelle technique pour
savoir quel est son groupe sanguin  est-ce qu'une
pomme l'a implémentée sur le kit de santé
n'est-ce pas donc donc l'aide qu'elle peut être peut en
faire partie, mais ce vers quoi nous devons nous diriger,
c'est où les données sont utilisées pour
certaines choses ne sont pas pour d'autres non alors
c'est seulement  utilisé à des fins médicales par
exemple pas pour la monnaie vérifier votre
assurance pas  pour vous vendre de la
publicité, donc ce n'est pas la confidentialité, il s'agit simplement
de verrouiller les données avec la
cryptographie, il s'agit de comprendre
parfois les réglementations, parfois juste
la compréhension culturelle ouais de ce
qu'il est approprié d'utiliser, les gens doivent en
parler que pensez-vous de
notre littératie numérique pensez-vous que c'est
nous avons suffisamment de littératie numérique en ce
moment parce que nous avons tous comme de gros téléphones
des téléphones portables mais en même temps il
ne semble pas que notre culture à son
égard soit aussi développée que je pense bien je
pense que des programmes comme celui-ci sont vraiment
très importants merci beaucoup  beaucoup de
gens boivent toujours, prenez juste ne le
prenez pas pour acquis ne vous contentez pas d'utiliser l'
application pour femmes pensez à savoir si elle est
cryptée pensez au social nous utilisons
la dernière application quel est le social qu'est-ce que
vous créez avant de créer un groupe d'
intimidateurs créez-vous  quelque chose qu'elle est utile
je pourrais l'utiliser à
des fins éducatives pensez à l'
impact social de ce que vous faites pensez à ce qu'il y a
sous le co  vers pensez à la façon dont les choses
fonctionnent lorsque vous concevez un réseau social
pensez à ce qu'une partie de la société que
votre réseau va créer mais nous
donnons tellement comme des données personnelles ce ne sont plus des
photos de photos de nos enfants
ce sont nos données biométriques c'est c'est c'est
beaucoup plus  plus gros pour être une violation avec
ces données puis avec notre voiture de
crédit disons carte de crédit disons notre DC ce
genre de problème pensez-vous que vous craignez
comme une sorte de 911 numérique
Je pense qu'en fait nous aurons un
point de basculement mais je pense que les gens  arriveront au
point où, comme ils ont de plus en plus
de données très personnelles
disponibles, ils se rendront de plus en plus
compte que vous savez que ce sont mes données mm-hmm
donc nous travaillons sur de nouvelles architectures
où oui j'ai mes données quand  Je l'obtiens
de l'hôpital, je peux le stocker sur mon
magasin de données où je contrôle qui y a
accès dans votre compagnie d'assurance,
vous voulez consulter les résultats de mes tests
, parlons-en, mais par défaut, je peux
montrer mes données avec moi-même. Je peux obtenir  un
spectacle  avec ma famille, mais si je contrôle l'
esprit, il y a tellement de données de
différents types ouais
qui me concernent, cela va en fait être très
stimulant pour moi de pouvoir faire des
choses, que ce soit pour l'aider à gérer ma vie
et quand les gens voient ça  ce pouvoir est
potentiellement disponible, je pense qu'ils seront
potentiellement un gros mouvement, mais mon
mouvement de données, ce sont mes données, je les possède, je peux
les conserver et je peux faire des choses
avec, donc vous possédez personnellement une application en cours d'exécution,
je pense que vous utilisez  se déplace est-ce vrai
je ouais je vois ouais pendant un moment et
vous ne craignez pas que d ces
données soient comme violées et reçoivent un cadeau à
donner donc c'est une préoccupation c'est une préoccupation
je préférerais de loin que je sois  j'espère que j'aimerais
passer à quelque chose où les données sont
directement, donc pas dans le cloud, mais dans mon
puits dans mon cloud mon cloud personnel,
c'est que vous avez été coupé en train de pirater des
ordinateurs à l'époque d'Oxford
et vous avez  été vous avez été interdit
d'utiliser ces ordinateurs maintenant
vous êtes bon vous '  revenons un peu en arrière,
c'était très mineur, donc mon en fait, donc ma forme
mon partenaire et plus et la physique valait
le cerveau derrière mais tout ce que nous avons fait, nous avons
utilisé l'imprimante que nous n'étions pas
censés utiliser mais nous avons été bannis  d'utiliser
le Prince juste pour utiliser votre impression
vient pour utiliser l'ordinateur ouais nous l'avons
utilisé un mauvais moment le piratage est devenu
un peu plus complexe que ça en
ce moment juste explorer ouais
ouais quelques dernières questions sur les
sciences de l'éducation il y a un grand débat ici  et le
Québec sur l'avenir de notre
système d'éducation si vous rencontriez notre
ministre de l'éducation que diriez-vous que lui diriez-
vous quels conseils vous lui donneriez sur
l'avenir de notre système d'éducation
soit deux choses une chose vraiment importante
qui enseigne le code aux gens  les gens
à apprendre aux gens à comprendre, en particulier les
femmes, car traditionnellement, il y a eu
un préjugé dans l'autre sens, apprenez à vos filles à
coder, faites-leur comprendre que vous vous
exposez à la possibilité d'être
créatif pour l'informatique  ter certains iront de cette
façon quelqu'un, que les gens deviennent programmeurs informatiques ou non,
encore faut-il qu'ils se
familiarisent avec les ordinateurs parce que si vous
êtes ministre si vous êtes au Parlement si
vous êtes juge si vous faites partie d'un jury, vous
devez  comprendre la technologie
parce que toutes nos vies sont consacrées à
essayer la technologie et donc pour être un
citoyen, vous devez la comprendre de
sorte que c'est quelque chose que le
système éducatif, je pense, doit vous
offrir plutôt une personne discrète
par rapport aux autres stars du web ou  des
stars du texte comme un Steve Jobs Bill Gates et
voudriez-vous voir un film
se fermer sur votre vie si quelqu'un en a
déjà fait un bon court mais ce qui
était bien c'était que le
point principal du film nous devions expliquer
le  avoir besoin de meubles à la neutralité du net
mm-hmm expliquerait la menace et
c'est donc la chose difficile à expliquer aux
gens à propos de la femme pour que quelqu'un prenne le
contrôle d'Internet pourquoi est-ce si mauvais que
pourraient-ils faire alors le film explique t  chapeau
c'est une chose difficile à expliquer donc je suis
très je lui suis vraiment reconnaissant de le
mettre je viens de voir les deux derniers
films de Steve Jobs ouais ouais ouais comment avez-
vous trouvé que ce que je ne savais pas que
j'étais dans le même  chambre comme Steve
j'aurais serait vraiment intéressant de l'avoir
rencontré il faisait le tour d'
un ensemble de projets qui utilisaient la prochaine
machine et la maison était là mais il a été
appelé et a dû aller ailleurs
tout libre à mi-chemin alors nous nous sommes presque
rencontrés  et donc ça aurait été
fascinant de médium je ne sais pas donc je ne peux pas
dire avec le mouvement si le film est
précis oh vraiment bien une question
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez que nous
sachions sur l'avenir du web quoi  devons-
nous que devons-nous savoir à ce
sujet pour l'année prochaine dont vous devez
vous occuper encore que vous si vous
pouvez passer quatre-vingt-quinze pour cent de votre
quatre-vingt-dix-neuf pour cent de votre vie à
utiliser le Web, mais l'autre  pour cent
s'il vous plaît pensez à le protéger pensez
à regarder  g à la législation qui
est en train d'être adoptée, est-ce que quelqu'un
essaie de mettre en place une législation dans votre
pays un autre pays qui essaie
de lancer une patrouille sur le Web regardez
les accords avec les grandes entreprises sont-
ils en fait en train de restreindre votre
liberté et si  utiliser nécessaire ce
pour cent de votre temps pour sortir et
protester pour que tout le monde lance un mouvement dont
vous avez besoin et je suis peut-être un activiste que
tout le monde doit faire si vous l'utilisez, vous
avez également une beauté pour les soins protecteurs
de votre site Web de son inventeur  c'est un
regard brillant après un tout dernier
message de mission à tim berners-lee merci
beaucoup pour votre temps et nous vous souhaitons
et nous vous souhaitons d'être là comme l'
air pendant longtemps merci Jérusalem
rapide Merci vers se